asientos de kilómetros de la línea del
frente en Rusia hasta allí consiguieron
llegar dos drones ucranianos que
estallaron en las bases aéreas de raizán
y saratov y que aunque fueron
interceptados se cobraron la vida de al
menos tres soldados
debido a la caída de las explosiones de
los restos de drones en los aeródromos
rusos el revestimiento de la carrocería
de dos aviones resultó dañado y tres
militares rusos técnicos que se
encontraban fueron heridos de muerte
daños que desde el otro bando el de las
fuerzas ucranianas a pesar de no
confirmar su autoría celebraron
Rusia Qué pasó una victoria fugaz y
opacada por la octava Ronda de
bombardeos de Rusia contra Ucrania en
ocho semanas en especial sobre Odessa y
zapodilla que volvieron a dejar al
suroeste del país sin electricidad en
medio de la oscuridad con temperaturas
por debajo de los cero grados
centígrados todo a pesar de que El
Ejecutivo ucraniano asegura que su
defensa aérea derribó al menos 60 de los
70 misiles lanzados
una prueba de que el terror puede ser
Derrotado Pero por desgracia todavía no
hay seguridad completa en nuestros
cielos por desgracia hubo víctimas
tenemos cuatro personas muertas debido a
estos ataques
ataques que hicieron sonar las sirenas
en kieva donde muchos ciudadanos se
refugiaron ante un posible ataque en
estaciones de metro
Espero que no haya destrucciones masivas
esperaron hasta que la temperatura
llegara a los cinco menos seis grados
centígrados hasta que hizo frío
todo mientras el presidente Vladimir
Putin visitaba El puente del estrecho de
kerch conduciendo un Mercedes Benz el
puente más grande de Europa que
conectaba la Península de crimea
anexionada por Rusia en 2014 Consuelo
ruso pero que el 8 de octubre sufrió un
atentado que los rusos achacan a las
fuerzas militares